بين اكياس الاسمده هذه خبيئت اطنان من
المواد المتفجره مواجهه لمليشيات الحوثي
في اليمن
القصه بدات يوم الثامن من نوفمبر في
المياه الدوليه لخليج عمان وعلى طول طريق
يستخدم تاريخيا لتهريب الاسلحه الى
الحوثيين اعترضت البحريه الامريكيه سفينه
صيد قادمه من ايران وافراد طاقمها
اليمنيين الاربعه اكثر من سبعين طنا من
وقود الصواريخ اثرت عليها البحريه
الامريكيه داخل قارب صيد لفتهم وزنه
الثقيل بسبب الشحنه الكبيره من المتفجرات
كما عثر داخل القارب على مئه طن من سماد
اليوريا التي يمكن استخدامها في تصنيع
لمده الجيرات
من المواد
اكثر من 10 صواريخ بالستيه متوسطه الماده
بالوقود حسب الحجم
قامت القوات الامريكيه باغراقه بعد تحديد
انه يشكل شكرا على الملاحه كما تم تسليم
الطاقه لخفر السواحل اليمنيين
لا يمر مرور الكرامه انه امر غير مسؤول
وخطير ويؤدي الى العنف وزعزعه الاستقرار
في جميع انحاء الشرق الاوسط
ت كذلك على ان اعمال التهريب التي تقوم
بها طهران خطيره وغير مسؤوله واكدت ان
التوريد المباشره او غير المباشر للاسلحه
او بيعها او تهريبها الى ميليشيات الحوثي
ينتهي فقرار مجلس الامن الدولي رقم
216 والقانون الدولي
عمليات وتهريب السلاح الايراني لمليشيات
الحوثي ليست بجديده بل وتسارعت في الاونه
الاخيره والامثله عديده ففي ديسمبر الماضي
ضبط الاسطول الامريكي الخامس شحنه بنادق
وذخيره في سفينه صيد قادمه من ايران كما
صادرت البحريه الامريكيه في يناير الماضي
40 طن من سماد اليوريا المتفجر على قارب
صيد ايراني كان في طريقه لامداد الحوثيين
ملوك الشيخ العربيه